okay well thanks thanks a lot to the
organizers for inviting me and the
Simon's Institute for their wonderful
hospitality um if you some of this is in
some sense a report on the fall on the
semester we had here about a year ago a
lot of things happened then and I'm now
kind of very excited about permanent
versus determined and it was a problem i
didn't have much hope for previously but
before that to relate to some themes of
this workshop I want to talk a little
bit about how a geometry would view
holographic algorithms so let's say um
let's say G is a row vector and it's
going to be a big one let's say sighs
say to em choose em so like four to the
m and so i'll write like g in i'm
working over the complex numbers chew em
choose em the dot star means row vector
and then I have another one a column
vector
and I want to compute this row column
multiplication so here's an example over
here so this is very big so it's not
going to be easy to do in general
there's no shortcut you basically need
order of 4 to the M arithmetic
operations to do it but you might be
able to do it less if G&R had special
shape so a particular example of that is
let's say so first of all if this
problem is even going to be in sharpie I
have to have some restriction on what
could be in my row vector and in my
column vector because otherwise just to
specify it you're not in polynomial
number of variables so we want to be
able to do this pairing at least talk
about the pairing with not so many
variables so I'm going to take variables
out of an m-by-n matrix
so I'll write it xij the eye for the
indexing the row and the J indexing the
column and I'm going to let G be the set
of all minors of the matrix so there's
the zero by zero minor which I just
indicate one and then I get all the
entries and then all the two by two
minors all the way up to determine it to
vex let's say I just ended up somebody
handed me a Vectra like that and the
vector R was similar going the other way
with the different matrix why
okay then this pairing this row column
this is why are this row column of
multiplication can actually be computed
very quickly just the determinant of the
n-by-n identity matrix plus x transpose
x y you could ask yourself well what
kind of vectors when does this miracle
occur and how how could you test I mean
how can you test if there's some
miraculous thing going on over here so
for those of you who are familiar with
some things in geometry this is actually
the case here there is a test
namely a test to see if my vector is a
vector of minors on this is this goes
because in geometric language this is
saying gee is in the grossmont ian of em
planes in two M dimensional space and
there's classical polynomials the test
for membership in that set so
polynomials can tell you whether the
vector somebody wrote down for you is a
vector of that form and similarly here
and so if those polynomial tests are
passed then you win you get a very quick
calculation just an M by M determinant
gives you your answer now so what
because this may never happen so let me
do a slight variant on it let's say um
now X is some skew symmetric matrix I'm
sorry but there's too many of these
palooka relations right you may not be
able to check them all right and the
reasonable time oh you don't need to
check all of them for set theoretic
membership yet I you need the comedy for
this district well the sooo many right I
think polynomial number of polynomials
to check this well I guess you're right
yeah yeah no your cuz it you're correct
but I'm gonna tell you something better
in all ears okay so let's do skew
symmetric matrices so skew symmetric you
can um if it's even size skew symmetric
matrix you can take the square root of
the determinant that's called the foffy
in' and so we could now let's say G is a
matrix of sub boffins
I always forget how to spell coffee on
some approximation of the spelling
that's the terrible thing about being
videotaped my ignorance they're out
there forever right and same thing of
with vector sort vector of sub coffee
ins and saying with our then there's a
similar fast pairing in terms of some
thought phien which I'm not going to
write it out on and what happens is so
this this now this will sit inside a
space of dimension exactly 2 to the M
there was a number of sub coffee ins of
a m or 2m x 2 n matrix and this one you
say well that I claim is actually what
what goes on and holographic algorithms
at least the classical case the first
you know the ones that got the headlines
about counting mod seven a problem that
you can't mod 20 and the pairing from a
mathematical point of view is just like
this it can be computed quickly because
you have these long vectors of sub
thought viens but you can bunch them up
and just computing one size M by M or 2m
x 2m ba phien now that's not exactly
what happens in holographic algorithms
because you're not so lucky that the way
you're handed to it is sub puffy ins so
this C 2 to the M we write as say C 2
tensor to the M so if you think about
previous lectures you have this graph
and you want consistency if this one's
labeled when you want this one to be
labeled 1 and so you have a c2 with a 0
or a 1 basis vectors and you
to choose whether you're 0 or whether
you're one consistently and you use is
so this C 2 to the M is really see 2m
copies and what the the fundamental idea
is also allow change a basis in situ
inducing the change in situ sensor to
the M and as long as you make the
corresponding change a basis on the
other side by stick a matrix here and
they stick the inverse matrix here they
won't change the row column product and
the amazing fact is
is it there exists Sharpie complete
problems that would phrase this way KO's
g and are that such changes a basis
so that is to say this pairing I could
put G in the good form and I could put
our in the good form and I can do it for
a short p hard problem but but they did
not prove p equals short p and the
reason they didn't prove it is because
unfortunately the change of basis needed
here in the change of basis needed here
we're different but sometimes over some
special fields or some special
situations you're able to use the same
change of basis and simplify in this
manner so I this is kind of a just a
short introduction talk to my actual
talk it has nothing to do with the rest
of it so if you have any questions on
this now is a good time to ask because
I'm going to spend the rest of the time
talking about something completely
different confused about what you mean
by saying she in orem it a chain it
changes so I I'm handed a gigantic row
vector G and that gigantic row vector G
comes from an instance of a sharp P
problem translated into this language
I'm skipping that because they've been
talking about this all week and this
vector are the this this sharpie problem
has been translated into language that
is equivalent to my counting problem is
equivalent to evaluating this row vector
column vector product ok now this row
vector is built up out of tiny vectors
that are kind of been mashed together
and these tiny vectors have a natural a
cheap a very inexpensive way to change
basis just a two-by-two matrix and
sometimes in fact in case of sharpie
hard problems there it's actually
possible to change basis such that I get
this nice format that it's ready to go
for a cheap super fast evaluation and
this one also that can be done for the
coolum is that usually you need a
different change of basis for both of
them but you could kind of this is I
just wanted to show people that there's
this geometric perspective on stuff
that's been talked about several days
here I know how rare is that so suppose
you want to salsa status variability you
think a formula and you pick an
assignment it sometimes you're lucky
there Simon fits but sometimes you're
not so just the same phenomena I cannot
comment on that
ok let's go on to the next talk so um
this is something this is stuff Jason
Sergei Noreen and I did a few years back
now I want to talk about stuff that is a
more recent and in fact stuff that
hasn't been done yet because that's
always the most interesting so that can
be very optimistic about the future so
um this is a story i'm sure everyone
here knows but i'm going to say it again
just to fix notation if that thing else
so so though it all goes back to a
theorem of alliant which says that it's
so this this for me is the notation
homogeneous polynomial degree m in Big M
variables so let me write like P of Y so
Y is y 1 up to Y M any polynomial and
then there exists exists some n which
depends on pay the polynomial and a
linear an affine linear map a from my
original space to the space of M by n by
n matrices so I have my y 1 y m maps to
and it's going to be an affine linear
map so it'll be some
a 0 plus summation j equals 1 to M a j
YJ such that p of y is the determinant
of this a of Y let me call this a tilde
and also so if we let DC of PDC for
determine ental complexity the smallest
and it works darling it also showed this
is a legitimate complexity measure
so I don't want to go into details but
if if you want to compute the polynomial
P with an arithmetic circuit this
determinant I'll complexity is related
to the size of that arithmetic circuit
or if you want to tree anything it's
it's not the same but you know during
the same book boat now for what comes
next and because I'm in geometry I like
linear maps better than a fine linear
maps and in fact memoli and suhani
fortunately already proposed this they
said well let's add an extra variable
and make it a linear map and then you're
not going to compute P but whatever
correct if the degree is M little m the
degree of this whole thing is n so you
have to put in that thing to make it the
same thing oh i forgot to say the
conjecture of course that the
determinant of complexity of this
polynomial we've been hearing about
every day grows faster than any
polynomial perhaps exponentially
okay so this is conjecture it's from the
1970s and then mammalian suhani had a
program so let me illustrate it with a
cartoon we're here and over here is
valiants conjecture
and they proposed a path so the first
step along the way is they said use
algebraic geometry
so to use algebraic geometry real what I
really mean is to use polynomials
algebraic geometry is the study of
polynomials and in this case will be
talking about polynomials on spaces of
polynomials so let me say how to do this
this doesn't look like algebraic
geometry but what we're going to do is
look for a polynomial P Apollo me let's
call it Q on the space of matrices on a
degree let me write it as sim and matrix
and by n so a polynomial on the space of
polynomials lady qm n such that Q 2 can
distinguish
things that can be written in that way
from the permanent to of P equals 0 for
all p let's say in the same space as the
permanent that admits and a tilde for n
so that's one property and 22 of the
permanent is not equal to 0 so if we
have a polynomial that's 0 on everything
that's easy to compute and it's nonzero
on the permanent the permanent cannot be
computed in this way and oh that's why I
wanted now we have to be careful here
because Q yeah we're really going to be
a Q Q's video really a queue will be a
polynomial on the sim n matrix matrices
so what our P is in the wrong space so
we have to look at this l to the n minus
m p and then we have to take some random
inclusion of cm squared plus 1 into CN N
squared any inclusion and any linear
conclusion because if I choose a
different one I can always change make a
change of basis here to work in that one
so I start with any inclusion and it'll
work so another way to say this is that
um want Q of P equal to 0 for all p
inside well what these aids can be they
can be there's you know m plus one of
them so what what this really is is the
orbit close
sure of the determinant polynomial so
orbit closure of determinant under all
possible change of basis
that is I think of my space of n by n
matrices as just a single vector space
of dimension n squared i have n squared
variables and a lot i allow myself
arbitrary linear changes of basis so
that's their first step along the path
they want to use polynomials any
questions about that first step
no okay let's go to the second step so a
fun
they don't they know that that's beneath
them that's sick I found polynomials but
no I found yeah well me and friends of
mine I have very good friends we found
one on and we were so so what is known
about this function of DC of perm m well
it's conjectured it's super polynomial
and all it's known as its greater than m
squared over 2 this is minyan andressa
air and um if you let this stronger
thing be called DC bar on width we
proved that this thing is also we get
the same bound this is with manorville
andressa air on the this was found by
finding an explicit polynomial Q so we
wrote one down we showed it vanished on
all the softies and did not vanish on
the permanent okay but it's only here so
we want it we want to go better right
and so the next step in the payoff is
use representation theory
and I'm going to continue this path in a
precise way I'll put a box there so what
is representation theory representation
theory is the study of symmetry in
linear algebra and what they want to do
is take advantage of the fact that the
determinant polynomial is very special
because of its symmetry group right i
mean if i have an n-by-n matrix and i
want to take the determinant of x i can
left multiply it by and by n matrix with
determinant one and right multiply it
and I get the same thing sometimes will
write this is in sln see so so this SL
and c plus SL and see it meds into well
the group preserving the determinant
which is the subgroup of all changes of
bases
and these are the changes the basis that
don't affect that don't change the
Charter minute changes the basis seiji
such G X where I think of my matrix as a
column vector now that their determinant
of G let me put a dot X is equal to
determinant of X so don't get confused
this is a column vector maybe so this X
is a size n square column vector not an
n-by-n matrix so this is really an N
squared by N squared matrix that does
not change it and this is this is most
of the symmetries of the determinant and
going back to frobenius uh basically if
you have any polynomial that is
invariant under a group that looks like
this it is the determinant up to scale
so the determinant is characterized by
its symmetry group if you know the
symmetry group you know it's the
determinant the permanent has almost the
same good luck where a and B could be
permutation matrices or and or or
combinations of diagonal matrices with
determinant one
notice that a permutation matrix half
the time does not have determinant one
so this is not a subgroup of that group
and it turns out that the permanent is
the unique polynomial that is invariant
under that group or any group that
contains it so the permanent is also
characterized by its symmetry group so
the essence of the memoli suhani idea is
not to study these particular
polynomials because that is viewed as
intractable it is unique polynomial up
to scale and variant under this group I
will prove it for you after the lecture
i can write down the proof the proof is
a non-trivial but the orbits face is
what dimension like 2 n 2 m 2 m minus to
the orbit of this pollen the orbit of
this group it's a finite group
semi-direct product to tour I it's a
very tiny group right so the dorm space
is roughly am square done right but that
if you look inside inside sim m of cm
squared it's the unique instance of the
ok let me say it in a higher-level
language it's unique the trivial
representation of this group occurs
exactly once in this vector space I
understand so what you meant to say that
it's fallen on all this degree is unique
of course of course because we fixed our
space yeah yeah of course you could
square the permanent I'd still be a very
tender to that group right I mean okay
so um so yeah so then they they have
another more sophisticated use
use of representation theory but I'm not
going to tell you about that for a very
good reason and it's not just that we're
almost out of time no no that the X does
not belong there sorry started that ruin
a ruined my whole talk sorry sorry sorry
sorry we're going to fix that news
representation theory going to hear and
the X goes here no so the theorem is no
and this is this is by a kid meyer and
panova and it's not only is it an
amazing theorem but the proof is also
amazing but our time together is limited
so you're not going to hear about that
so this is out and then there was
another path using algebraic geometry
proposed by g kk s names are written
there on that is the so-called method of
shifted partial derivatives
I don't have time to discuss this method
but needless to say there's a so called
method of partial derivatives which was
introduced about 150 years ago by
Sylvester and rediscovered in the 1990s
by computer scientists and this is an
augmentation of that method and then um
there I they they proved a result that
got people excited and then their next
step was to work harder because they had
a very tantalizingly close conclusion
that they thought they were really close
to I can't go into it but I can go into
this and this is with my collaborators
and what I want to say about their
method is they this theorem actually was
was quite easy to prove in night so
their method involves two parameters AK
and a cow doesn't matter what those
parameters are and for like ninety
percent of the parameter choices k and
tau it was very easy to prove their
method was not going to work but there
was there was one point where there was
some sort of very strange choice of K
and tau and those are functions of em of
course that seemed to that we had to
work really really hard to prove but we
did um but that indicated that why not
this is a this is a augmentation of a
method that's 150 years old why not
augment this method further
well that's of course you can say well
let's generalize more but in fact we
already had developed a theory that
included this method is a special case
and for the particular augmentation we
have in mind we're actually quite
hopeful that's some commutative algebra
namely the study of minimal free
resolutions might actually lead to some
new lower bounds I'm not going to say
it's going to be a path because we don't
have enough data yet but I would not be
surprised if we could beat this number
by using more commutative algebra so
that's another tool from algebraic
geometry more explicitly the minimal
free resolutions now I was told that if
I did not run over you would not respect
me but I also know that if I do run over
I won't respect myself so I'm going to
keep my self-respect and rush through so
I have a little bit more on the menu to
discuss right so now I'd like to talk
about yep so so I'm done talking about
these so I just gave you a hint about
that so let's talk about this so um yeah
so I'm told it's totally cool in
computer science too because you can't
prove any of your theorems that none of
your conjectures you can't prove them by
the way I thank you for your patience
tolerating a mathematician and your
conference on but it is strange for me
this kind of thing that you nobody can
prove anything so what do they do they
prove something under so-called
restricted models so so I I'm going to
be inspired by this use representation
theory useless I I think melilla and so
honey had a a essential point they make
here that the fact that just knowing
these groups tells you your polynomial
is a very profound thing and so we
should use that so
I'm going to need a slight definition
here of equivariant so I'll keep that up
so we have this a i guess it's called a
tilde a tilde from this cm2 this space
of matrices and on this space we have
this group that preserves the
determinant acts here and on this space
whatever our polynomial is we have the
group preserving our polynomial and it
preserves p so in geometry it's very
natural to look for maps that respect
the group action and by that we call an
equivariant so what I ask is a tilde is
GP equivariant if for all elements of my
group there exists let's say um a oh I
used aid to different this let's call
that script day and script me there
exists script a of G and script be of G
such that a tilde of G acting on my Y is
equal to this a of G a tilde of Y B of G
so in other words i can either act by
this group here or i have a map of this
group into this group and i can act
after before or after and we can define
the equivariant determine ental
complexity of p is the smallest
and such that there exists in
equivariant so for example the
equivariant determine ental complexity
of the determinant is equal to the
determinant of complexity of the
determinant which is just m for an M by
M determinant because you could just
take the identity map and the identity
map is certainly equivariant and if p is
generic p generic then no group will
preserve it so then ed cfp is also equal
to DC of P so with the extremes you get
exactly the same number but for special
polynomials you probably won't and our
main theorem is that this equal very
determine ental complexity of the
permanent is 2m choose M minus 1 exactly
so under this restricted model you can
prove an exponential separation
now of course that's good for you know
impressing the folks back home
dinnertime conversation but how is it
going to help us with the original
conjecture well the were certain tools
we had to introduce to prove this
theorem these tools um I do not have
time to get into but the tools of the
proof do not have anything to do with
equal variance they have to do with
certain properties of permutation groups
and certain a certain endo functor that
I don't have time to get into and as a
result of those tools we expect we can
use them to maybe improve again this
lower bound on determine ental
complexity a little bit I don't know how
far it will take us so um now I'm in the
embarrassing situation of ending early
so this this is a little complicated but
let me let me say a little bit about
this in the last five minutes so I can
tell you at least I do do proofs it's
just yeah so we can do actually prove
something in the next five minutes or
are there questions
so I'm sorry goof is acting it down
there in the space of matrices well in
the case of people there down there yeah
yes this is the determinant this is this
is exactly a and B are n by n matrices
with determinant one so someone hands
you at element of this group variant on
their big group right right but this is
the image of so here I have cm squared
so I have my M by M matrix call it Z and
then or let's call it Y and then I have
my new matrix a tilde of why and what
I'm saying is that the permanent will we
know the permanent of y is equal to the
permanent of G why because G is in the
group preserving the permanent yeah but
then we've also know that the permanent
of y is equal to the determinant of a
tilde of Y just so this the small group
that ass down there right into it
there's and there's a group homomorphism
of this small group into this big group
and this big group i'm ignoring the of
just looking at the connected component
the identity so this is basically a pair
of n by n matrices with determinant one
so i get my first n by n matrix my
second n by n matrix and you see we know
let me just finish it here we have that
the determinant of a tilde of gy is of
course on the permanent of gy and we
have that this is equal to the
determinant of this is equal to the
determinant of a tilde why but this is
kind of a stronger assertion that I I
could act I could preserve this
polynomial by any pairs of matrices here
but what I'm asking is a stronger thing
that not only is the polynomial
preserved but the map yeah
prove that acts there right yes and this
big group that is there right which I
which big group in the bigger space you
have in the bigger space we have this
group in the smaller space we have this
group oh hey on mix that out this is the
small group a tax on the small space
this is the big group it acts on the big
space and I claim there's a group
injection of the small group into this
group big group that commutes with this
map and that's the extra hypothesis
that's the restricted model it's no
restriction for the determinant and it's
no restriction for generic polynomial
risers formula doesn't produce any
favorite equally variant ya know it's
risers formulas is a little smaller than
this well the there's an improvement on
risers formulas slightly smaller than
this it's close though but it's it's
also different complexity measures so we
have to be careful uh-uh well I will
still say a few words about at least the
first thing the scooped come off thing
so if I have a polynomial see polynomial
say homogeneous 3 n then um I can use
that to get a map from this is the
differential operators what are ok to
homogeneous polynomial of degree n minus
K namely my differential operator I just
start taking a bunch of derivatives of P
and this linear map uh if he is a
generic polynomial this linear map will
be a maximal rank and so the failure of
this linear map to be of maximal rank is
a measure of the pathology of my
polynomial P and we can measure the
failure of this thing to be maximal rank
by polynomials by
taking minors so the smallest minors
that vanish or you know if if all the
size seven miners vanished that means
that p is pretty darn pathological and
this is the complexity measure that is
over a hundred years old Gupta come off
and Kyle augmented it thank you I can
augment this by taking d and another
polynomial Q and I just take the
derivatives and then I multiplied by Q
and this is their method of shifted
partial derivatives if you're an
algebraic geometry you stay oh they're
taking Hilbert functions of jacobian
ideals and once you open up that can of
worms Hilbert function of Jacobian
ideals you can go on and say well
there's more refined things we can look
at in these Jacobian ideals we can look
at minimal free resolutions and other
things and extract other equations like
that thank you for your attention yes so
in the in the setup where you have you
know the determinant being acted on my
SL to cross sl2 isn't it also the case
that the determinate is the unique
polynomial for scalar just being acted
on by a single copy of SL to FL n sorry
there's only yes and you are correct and
we actually that is so we also talked
about like half equivariant and what
motivated our paper was um a theorem of
al perro Bogart and Alaska which came
out of our workshop which proved that
grenades formula for the three by three
permanent is a seven by seven
determinant was optimal and we said
there's a basic philosophy in geometry
that if you have an optimal algorithm it
should have some interesting geometry
and we discovered that grenades formula
is actually half equivariant and that no
so half equivariant is less fun to say
the neck were buried so
had live in at a time so I didn't
mention that in the talk but that was
actually our starting point front of
fractions
so if you put the coffee on a space on
your permanent we have not looked at
that but it will be polynomial actually
because we're looking what we looked at
verse is even the crazier thing of the
determinant I'll complexity of the
determinant where we handicap ourselves
and we force this matrix to be of rank n
minus 1 which must be the case for the
permanent by vons or gotten serum and
already there you get some very
interesting things going on
I dream I hello thoughts for the CDC for
any other phone number yeah there's a
well it depends what you mean by
interesting but there's a few in our
paper so quad Rex and I mean yeah the
proof is not the proof for the permanent
is like non highly non-trivial so you
have to use some delicate things about
the permutation group that you know so I
wouldn't if the group if the group is
like Ali group or something then it's
probably pretty easy to check but if the
group is some is some mostly some finite
group then it's very delicate